humans don't have fur like many of our
ancestors but our bodies still have the
ability to adapt to cold weather
however when pushed these mechanisms can
fail leading to an extreme breakdown so
what actually happens to your body and
brain when you freeze to death
hypothermia occurs when the core body
temperature drops below 37 degrees
Celsius so in the event that the body is
exposed to extreme cold within minutes
signals are sent from the skin to the
hypothalamus producing what is known as
the thermal effector responds first the
blood vessels in our skin narrow
allowing the body to maintain its core
temperature by reducing the blood flow
on its surface known as phase o
constriction additionally brown adipose
tissue located throughout the body also
activates using high levels of glucose
and lipids to produce heat via a process
called non shivering a thermogenesis but
if all else fails our body undergoes
shivering thermogenesis as a last-ditch
effort by constantly contracting our
skeletal muscles our body induces
shivering in an attempt to produce
enough heat to prevent hypothermia
however if you remain exposed to the
cold within 30 minutes you could get
frostbite which is when your skin and
the tissues literally begin to freeze
developing ice crystals endanger your
cells by damaging their cell membranes
causing intracellular dehydration due to
water leaking out from them the cells
then begin to die and the ice crystals
continue to expand damaging neighboring
cells in response the body tries to
prevent frostbite in our skin through
vasodilation which allows increased
blood flow to warm the skin cells
however this runs counter to the thermal
effector response which again works to
maintain our core temperature through
vasoconstriction as a result our body
goes through cycles of vasodilation and
vasoconstriction dying and freezing our
skin over and over again and causing
even more damage but our skin isn't the
only spot that will freeze under extreme
cold temperatures if you're in extreme
cold windy weather your corneas can
freeze too the protective layer of tears
covering the cornea can try making your
eyes sensitive to light and causing
eyelid spasms luckily your corneas can
thaw if you get yourself out of the cold
quickly but if frozen long enough you
can
permanent damage now several factors
including body composition clothing
temperature and the environment
determine how quickly your core body
temperature drops for example heat is
lost much more quickly in water than in
air those who were submerged in the icy
waters after the sinking of the Titanic
may have lasted only 15 minutes this is
because during the advanced stage of
hypothermia your organs begin to fail
your breathing rate slows you lose
coordination your heart rate begins to
slow down and your body even stops
shivering
one of the last symptoms of advanced
stage hypothermia is delirium a survey
of cases in which death was caused by
hypothermia found that in 25% of the
cases the victims had undressed before
they died in one case victims had neatly
folded their clothes beside them and
froze to death in the snow why would
this happen one theory is that the brain
damage that results from the extreme
cold causes people to think that they're
burning up so they stripped naked and
cooled down another theory suggests that
the muscles that caused cutaneous
vasoconstriction in our blood vessels
get exhausted and cause blood from our
core to rush to the surface of our body
resulting in a hot flash this is all
pretty bleak but if you find someone who
appears to be frozen to death you may
want to warm them up an aptly named
paper no one is dead until warm and dead
Chronicles a patient with hypothermia
caused by drowning with no signs of life
this patient was successfully
resuscitated with a 3-hour bypass
surgery used to warm his body though
parts of his body required amputation in
11 weeks he successfully recovered with
normal neurological function just
remember when the temperature starts to
drop do everything you can to stay warm
because your body can only do so much to
fight the extreme cold so what are the
techniques to help your body survive
freezing to death we made a video of
step-by-step strategies to stay alive if
you're ever trapped in the extreme cold
click here to learn the life-saving but
also gruesome things need to know to
avoid hypothermia and freezing to death
with climate change causing extreme
weather we may all need this info in the
future
and subscribe for more weekly science
videos